c'est reparti pour un tour alors que la
prochaine élection miss france approche
à grands pas de nouvelle polémique
autour du concours de beauté font leur
apparition cette fois ci ce ne sont pas
les accusations de grossophobie du
concours qui sont au coeur de la
polémique mais une nouvelle guerre entre
sylvie tellier l'actuelle présidente du
comité miss france et geneviève de
fontenay visage historique du concours
au coeur de la discorde plusieurs sujets
dont la prochaine tenue de miss lorraine
cette dernière avait prévu de défiler
dans un costume de poilus pour rendre
hommage aux soldats de la première
guerre mondiale
interrogé par le parisien sur le sujet
des potentiels candidats transgenres qui
souhaiteraient participer au concours
sylvie tellier ne s'est pas montrée
hostile à l'idée
demain c'est une femme ou un garçon
ayant changé de sexe ayant donc un état
cgt mines 1 se présente au concours miss
france nous ne sommes pas la police
je ne vais pas le faire passer de visite
médicale une nouvelle déclaration qui a
fait bondir la dame au chapeau
je suis évidemment contre une miss
france transgenres une identité sexuelle
ou psychique qui ne correspond pas au
sexe biologique de la naissance je
défendrai l'image de miss france que
j'ai préservé pendant plus d'un demi
siècle jusque dans ma tombe
sylvie tellier a confirmé que si le
public le désir et elle ne s'opposerait
pas à l'entrée de candidats transgenre
dans le concours
même si pour elle ce choix est peu
probable il n'existe déjà pas une miss
ballon d'auvergne qui fait 1 42 ou 1,44
alors selon vous faut-il ouvrir le
concours miss france aux candidates
transe alors ça a été un truc
aujourd'hui incroyable alors qu'est-ce
que les tranchant parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens aussi qui dit voile
alors c'est des individus 30 jours on
les attribue biologique d'un sexe tout
en ayant le sentiment profond
d'appartenir à l'autre sexe
voilà alors les personnes transsexuelles
ont contrairement aux transgenres
entrepris de changer de sexe pour être
en accord avec le france antilles
profond certains se contentent de
simples traitements hormonaux alors que
d'autres recours à la chirurgie voilà
comme ça au moins on a replacé les
choses alors faut-il ouvrir le concours
miss france aux candidats trans sylvie
tellier la directrice du comité miss
france a avoué qu'elle était prête à
ouvrir le concours aux candidates ayant
changé de sexe dans une interview elle a
dit ça pour le parisien lundi le
concours miss france est simple il faut
être une femme entre 18 et 25 ans pour
concourir demain si une femme ou un
garçon ayant changé de sexe ayant donc
un état civil féminin se présente au
concours miss france
nous ne sommes pas la police je ne vais
pas lui faire passer de visite médicale
et elle a dit qu'elle pourrait pas
vérifier aussi
voilà voilà voilà voilà le règlement
chercher cet écrit né de sexe féminin et
ma pensée de sexe féminin tout court
alors exactement s'il dit
tellier corrige le règlement sur
internet qui stipule qu'il faut être né
de cette fille c'était le vieux
règlement de geneviève de fontenay donc
le règlement actuel de l'émission c'est
être de sexe féminin
donc maintenant c est faux est de sexe
féminin maintenant aux élections voilà
exactement alors il ya john dfk réagi
alors à votre avis ici auto nab avant
qu'on découvre les les miss
sélectionnées
bien entendu qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous vous êtes favorable ah oui
parce que vous avez tout dit il ce sont
des gens qui sont mal mais qui sont les
hommes qui sont femme vraiment à
l'intérieur d'un maire mais ça marche
dans les deux sens et ils sont pas nés
dans le bon comme moi je comprends très
bien que une fois qu'ils ont compliqué
la transformation pourquoi ne parler un
concours de beauté si son très beau moi
ça me dérange pas du tout vous savez on
se parlera pas du tout vous êtes pour
vous avez vu que si on est plus que j'ai
envie de savoir l'avis du public dans un
instant ça m'intéresse à fond ça de
savoir ce que vous en pensez alors il ya
plein de ya plein je vous dis aussi de
deux personnalités
voilà qui se sont engagés il ya jean
paul gaultier kennedy qui a été le pré
le président du jury de miss france
s'est dit favorable à ce qu'une femme
tronc se présente au concours il avait
dit sur europe 1 en mars 2018 vous dit
me mohamed vous dit non non alors déjà
je pense que le concours miss france est
un concours rétrogradé de voir des
filles en maillot de bain a déjà ça vous
dérange chaîne dérange suis pas sûr
qu'en 2019 on est besoin de ça mais
elles sont libres de le faire là où je
suis je suis pour l'inclusion évidemment
des personnes trans dans la société
je ne suis pas sûr que les abords dans
miss france permettra d'avoir un emploi
de permettre à ne pas être agressés dans
le métro d'abord une meilleure image de
ces personnes à la société mais
lorsqu'on parle de personnes trans elles
vont probablement avoir recours à la
chirurgie esthétique fana ce qui est
plutôt normal c'est un argument qu'on
peut comprendre parce que ça fait partie
de la transformation
lorsque vous voulez finalement d'avoir
une poitrine pas forcément vous avoir
recours à la chirurgie ses tig et donc
ces personnes trans auront accès à la
chirurgie esthétique et pourquoi pas les
autres
donc à partir du moment où on a accès à
cette chirurgie tout le monde peut le
faire et je pense que ça dénature le
concours miss france on aura des femmes
qui vont se refaire le nez repas des
sans abri et donc le coût n'est
finalement pas au concours donne dans le
règlement de miss france à la loi et à
faire de la chirurgie esthétique c'est
le fun véritable problème c'est que le
règlement de miss france est qu'on ne
doit pas en france avoir de chirurgie
esthétique au châtiment forcément il
faut changer le règlement à papi et
mamie là vous vous êtes pour alors vous
moi je suis plus exactement pour les
raisons que vous avez très bien mis dans
le dans l'énoncé savoir abattoirs ménard
le mauvais corps et qu'on retrouve son
corps d'origine pourquoi l'interdire en
revanche effectivement il ya le problème
de règlement parce qu'il est clair
il ne doit pas y avoir de survie donc
vous allez donc vous faire une case à
part pour les transgenres
quand je suis allé comprendre le
principe de cash flows au filtre mais
juste à côté vous êtes toujours vous
êtes oui mais je tenais non enfin on va
falloir dire les choses mais oui un
problème le règlement je m'en fous oui
mais il faut un gros teams pied dans
chaque camp
non mais ça donne ça tout part de là ne
leur à la télé on a fait dans chaque
camp on plaint de ce qu'il soit au
milieu
oui alors moi je ne suis pas du tout
progressé alors oui je suis complètement
rétrograde et pourtant j'adore 10 me le
concours miss france donc je propose
pour passer un concours miss france
transgenres par exemple quoique alors a
pas aimé ça peut être ni feuille de nori
terre et aujourd'hui on est en train de
crever de supprimer les critères loria
des hommes il ya des femmes
il ya des baux il ya des moches une
action ballon d'or et la quillane roland
garros on n'est pas tous égaux
il ya la dictature aujourd'hui de
l'égalitarisme et ça c'est dans les
pires des dictatures langue anglaise a
du sens pour moi non pas du tout il faut
des cris titre il ya des critères on
n'est pas tous pareils il ya des beaux
iliad est moche c'est pas pareil à des
gros ya des mamans pas pareil donc voilà
d'accord les gros de mai mais voilà et
donc du coup je suis absolument contre
soi disant sous couvert de progressisme
on est en train de courir cet hypocrite
et complètement là alors c'est alors
alors on va grandement des succès du
correctif ça se fait voilà rétifs
il va vous donner la parole dans un
instant alors vous êtes de quel
collectif merci les deux on va vous
donner la parole de la star ne vous
inquiétez pas là je vous le dis pour
défendre le oui je compte beaucoup sur
agathe parce que les trois autres îles
sera vachement compliqué vous avez toute
la pression parce que on peut pas dire
vous soyez très très bien entouré allez
c'est parti
oui je suis pour il n'y a rien de plus
conservateur et arriérée qu'un concours
de beauté le concours de miss france en
premier évidemment qu'il faut aller vers
une modernisation du processus et du
concept
les candidates actuels qui sont très
sympa très jolies elles se font tous
plus ou moins
le même poids elles ont toutes plus ou
moins la même taille évidemment il faut
qu'elle soit dans ce concours
mais on faisait le même débat ici la
semaine dernière sur les femmes rondes
qui était injustement exclu les
candidates actuelle qu'on va voir et qui
sont toutes très très belle ne
représente absolument pas ce qu'est la
société d'aujourd'hui l'inca murakami ce
qui représente 16 unis série la plus
belle qu'est-ce que je te coupe la
parole quand tu parles de couper sa
coupe se laisser finir madame louis
c'était le nom mais et le concours de
miss france donc si vous voulez que ce
soit un concours de la beauté en quoi
les femmes qui sont présentées
actuellement représente la beauté pour
qui que ce soit je suis sûr que si on
fait un sondage dans la rue quatre ans a
conquis poste des photos agathe est très
belle et tu représente la beauté et
ouvre aussi par exemple je poste des
photos ça représente pas la beauté de
leurs représentants on n'est pas tous
les mêmes égaux face à la beauté farid
très belle vous le savez tout comme
isabelle tout comme à gatwick au cri
torrentielles et la wii sont les jeux
les agat je suis désolé mais tu es
complètement à côté de la plaque est ce
que je vais te dire je la côte là ça va
remettre ça mais voilà les mots en
allemand par elsevier la flamme
ménagères - dont cyril fabre leurs 30
ans mais les portraits dvg la ménagère
de moins de 50 ans la femme la plus
jolie qui représente qu'il a raison
c'est la raison donc si c'est pourquoi
pas lors des séries une majorité de
forcer l élu par france
[Musique]
gâteaux pour la vous dit des bêtises au
sujet de ces trouvé de ne pas me trouver
représenté par ces marques comme les
autres sera 4 on a vu nos alors attendez
ya pas mal au coeur on était dans une
soirée que jean michel maire il rappelle
un étang tu as parlé à une copine qui
s'appelle pénique est génial et qui
étrangers n'est fini
[Applaudissements]
c'est à dire que la fille elle est
exceptionnelle jean mathieu est d'abord
c'est sain c'est pas la charge et
éthique c'est des hormones qu'elle prend
d'accord déjà pour bien pas confondre la
chirurgie esthétique qui avec le
bistouri qui n'a rien à voir avec les
blés les piqûres ou les meubles et des
cachets qu'on leur donne enfin et c'est
pour avoir vous avez déjà faut savoir
qu'au départ tous ces gens qui sont ces
filles qui sont transgenres son égard
sont elles ont déjà une féminité
excessive souvent déjà la naissance
c'est un dérèglement hormonal
donc c'est des garçons non mais gagner
garçon exceptionnel qui d'un seul coup
ils se sont mal dans leur peau y sont
mais c'est pourquoi quelques albums mais
parce que c'est un concours féminité on
peut avoir des garçons qui ont une part
féminine exceptionnel est d'ailleurs un
garçon comme jean michel tu t'es trompé
quand tu as vu penny je veux dire
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non tout bien tout honneur en dames et
d'un décès sur des médicaments mais non
mais c est la fille elle était sublime
et bing la collecte du mois mais debout
non là on a le camp de la bien pensante
qui nous dit qu'il faut c'était plus
nous on aurait les méchants personnes
qui veulent pas des personnes revenant
là quand tu nous expliques ça de ciudad
bon vous a pas coupé les républicains
ladagnous 10 cd personne fantastique
elles sont gentilles oui mais c'est
parce qu'on dis le moi je pense qu'ils
sont complètement hypocrite hypocrite il
se rachète une virginité en disant on va
inclure les gens dans la société mais
derrière c'est les mêmes qui vont
lorsqu'on a un peu trop gros les mettre
de côté
mais sous couvert de critère social
mettre des personnes trans pourquoi pas
des personnes un peu en surpoids des
homosexuels pourquoi pas des bisexuels
pourquoi est-ce qu'on ouvre tout d'un
coup simplement outrance le concours il
est tel qu'il est mais derrière on aura
un écrémage et derrière elles ne seront
pas mises en avant et elles ne seront
jamais élus
c'est juste une vaste hypocrisie mais en
tout cas lors leur but des 30 c'est de
justement d'être invisible d'un soutenez
c'est pas qu'on les pointes du vous avez
dit non même l'eurovision par exemple
gagne le même sens d'aller danser pour
leurs opinions
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
avec comme sita murs mais c'était ça
soulevait le même débat c'était interne
sera coupée justement m'excuser mais l'a
pour l'instant ce côté là je les
téléspectateurs le haut prix c'est pas
vous qui allez défendre le jeu basique
abbassi j'aimerais dire à quoi on va
l'aborder mais un porc laqué ni kinois
pour ne prendre qu as-tu bonsoir moi
aussi d'accord avec mes collègues
merci qui mais si on considère que l'art
six personnes et mal et aucun garçon qui
se sent femme mais non mais quelle est
la démarche et qui devient femme pour la
loi cette femme qui est donc une femme
n'irai pas un concours de beauté est
encore une occurrence à miss france
qu'est ce qui vous dérange là dedans
après plus rien
[Rires]
l'ena pour les femmes ça j'avoue que les
précédents volets les lycées publics a
choisi ou non mais c'est l'une des voies
n'est pourquoi le dire mais quand je
vous ai pas d'accord non mais on l'a
charmé la finalité des choses
où est notre avis peu importe c'est le
public qui choisit à l'arrivée c'est lui
qui aura raison s'ils votent pour cette
fille qu'elle est belle c'est qu'elle
est belle fille vous avez vu la voiture
devrait tout public qui aura le dernier
mot comme toujours ce qu'ils veulent
c'est ça les belles oui mais là où il
avait la pâte or c'est qu'on pourrait
ces personnes pourraient se présenter si
elles n'ont pas recours à la chirurgie à
dire mais on ne le serait pas mais dans
ces cas là pourquoi le mettre en avant
ce critère est en dix ans les personnes
trans venez chez nous on est bien
pensants ne rien dit et si on s'en rend
pas compte
c'est de la pure qu'il ya d'étrange on
va parler on a dit que c'est rétrograde
qu'on exclut les femmes qui serait un
peu un peu forte et banon se dit on se
rachète une virginité moi c'est bien la
société de dire ça il faut reconnaître
que notre position elle fut j'irai
défendre piocelle en face c'est une
connerie ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais d'après nos prénoms bikini c'était
de pois chiches tu venais voir dans le
bikini est si populaire c'est compliqué
voilà alors les cherry on va perdre son
public après tout vous dévoiler les
miches et oui vous allez nous dire parce
que ça y est ce sera le 14 décembre
prochain on a les 30 candidats en
compétition
ouais ouais ouais allez vas-y d'abord
qu'est-ce qui se passe
oui ou non soit 5 1% galant mais louis a
été très mal d'efforts et c'est
d'ailleurs comme ça je joue avec mes le
oui c'est une catastrophe ans